Wow I've learned a lot about tearing
tonight more than a thought I work
tonight anyway only one person can boast
about being the only boxer to win the
world Commonwealth and European Games
titles as well as being a double Olympic
champion and may I add first-ever
boxing women's Olympic champion back in
2012 and for those of you who don't know
that is every title an amateur boxer can
possibly win and this year she turns
professional and so far remains unbeaten
she's an inspiration to every aspiring
young athlete and quite honest I think
she would be anti Joshua in a fight I
honestly do anyway the glamour W channel
sportswoman of the year is Nicola Adams
thank you everyone and thank you glamour
and alone we can do so little but
together we can do so much I'm accepting
this award tonight not just for me but
for every woman that's had to fight a
battle to win a war and this is for you
and I like to thank every one men and
women that have supported me through my
career and thank you the futures female
Ajay
[Applause]